leapin honey i shrunk the Octavia that
was Emmanuel's first thought when he saw
Scott his new Fabia stationwagon
now he's going to see how it drives the
Fabia combi badged as the Fabia estate
in the UK is one of the most popular
wagons in its class it's low price has
made it a top seller
now Skoda is upping the ante even
further it's taken the best elements of
the old model and refined or expanded
them our test car is fitted with the
most powerful engine currently offered a
1.2 liter gasoline engine
once it's overcome the initial turbo lag
the 81 kilowatt age and feels more
sporty than sensible coupled with a
manual transmission it propels the car
from 0 to 100 km/h in 9.6 seconds those
who take their time and meet the new
European driving cycle criteria can get
fuel consumption of less than 5 liters
per 100 kilometers the Fabia combi
engine range currently comprises three
gasoline units and two diesels
would you take a seat in the back of the
Fabia combi says Emmanuelle you almost
forget that this car is from the compact
segment he finds the legroom quite
remarkable at first glance kotas new
design language doesn't deliver on the
dynamic new image the brand had promised
you have to look at the details
scooters wing arrow logo occupies a
prominent place between the crisp
contours on the hood the rear - is worth
taking a closer look
unlike the models that came before at
the Fabia combi features simply clever
solutions
these include this partition that
ensures small objects don't go flying
around in the trunk when it's not fully
packed when you do need the whole trunk
space it can be easily removed and
stored dr. Madani complete a lot of
cupboards if it'sif off you go
the Fabia wagon has 530 litres of trunk
space not enough just flip the rear seat
bench down and you have almost 1,400
various cargo nets are distributed
throughout the trunk drawback the
annoying height of the seat bench when
flipped down
out on the street amana puts the new
Fabia suspension to the test
what's his impression he calls the Fabia
suspension conspicuously inconspicuous
assuming you don't try to break any
speed records on curves in that case it
can feel a little sluggish front assist
is available as an optional extra it
applies the brakes when detecting a risk
of collision on this front the Fabia can
easily keep pace with the systems
offered by its competitors
the man was impressed by the Fabia combi
z-- interior he really likes the black
high-gloss trim of course the car is
fitted with a lot of hard plastic but
given its price that's hardly surprising
the high-gloss finish is available in
various colors the Fabia also boasts
comfy seats and a nice instrument layout
though anyone wanting to use the sat-nav
has to cope with a tangle of cables
scoota has equipped the Fabia combi with
mirrorlink this system permits dashboard
operation of compatible smartphones it
mirrors the screen on the phone letting
the driver use navigation apps or listen
to their music the built-in sat-nav
won't be available until the end of May
in overall Emmanuelle is impressed by
the Fabia combi and anyone who can do
with a little less trunk space in
comparison to the Octavia can save
themselves a little cash